hemos hablado un poco sobre la ley de la
demanda que nos dice que si todo lo
demás se mantiene igual si elevamos el
precio de un producto entonces la
cantidad de la demanda de dicho producto
se irá hacia abajo tienen sentido y si
bajamos el precio entonces la cantidad
demandada se desplazará hacia arriba va
a aumentar la cantidad de demanda y esto
lo hemos visto con algunos casos
especiales lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es centrarme en estas otras cosas
que hemos mantenido iguales las cosas
que nos permiten realizar esta
declaración es decir aquellas cosas que
no son ni la cantidad de demanda ni el
precio que tenemos del producto lo que
quiero ver es cómo cambia la curva real
por lo tanto en esta ocasión en lo que
me quiero centrar es en el precio de los
productos de competencia el precio de
los productos de competencia así que si
usted asume que el precio no nos espera
en realidad no digo que compiten los
productos voy a decir el precio de los
productos relacionados el precio de los
productos relacionados porque vamos a
ver que no forzosamente todos están
compitiendo este precio de los productos
relacionados es una de las cosas que
suponemos
cuando nosotros hablamos de la ley de la
demanda es decir se está llevando a cabo
igual cuando nosotros mostramos esta
relación nosotros estamos asumiendo que
estas cosas no están cambiando ahora qué
pasaría si estas cosas cambian es decir
en una primera instancia vamos a suponer
que los precios de los otros libros
electrónicos suben de precio así que
entonces qué es lo que haremos con
nuestra relación del precio y la
cantidad demandada si suben los precios
de los otros libros electrónicos ahora
todos de repente van a querer mi libro
electrónico sin importar qué punto del
precio estamos en cualquier punto de
esta gráfica mi libro electrónico va a
ser más deseable para el precio de dos
pesos es más probable que la gente
prefiera este libro que los otros libros
porque los otros son más caros por lo
tanto más personas lo van a querer es
decir la cantidad de personas que van a
querer comprarlo va a aumentar en cuatro
pesos más personas lo van a querer en
seis pesos más personas van a querer en
ocho más personas lo van a querer y en
diez más personas lo van a querer así
que si esto llegara a suceder
realmente cambiaría la curva de la
demanda por completo hacia la derecha se
vería algo
si o se va a ver algo así y este va a
ser mi escenario número 1 en el cual
como ya dijimos lo que va a pasar es que
los precios de los otros libros
electrónicos va a aumentar y bueno el
nombre de los otros libros electrónicos
se les conoce como sustitutos de mi
producto éstos son los sustitutos de mi
producto y esto es porque la gente
podría decir oh sabes el otro libro
parece algo comparable si uno es más
caro y uno es más barato pues tal vez
leeré uno u otro así que con el fin de
hacer esta declaración para mantener a
lo largo de esta curva tenemos que
asumir que esto es constante si lo que
pasa es que esto va a cambiar entonces
se va a mover la curva si suben los
precios de otros libros electrónicos
probablemente cambiarán nuestra curva
hacia la derecha si los precios de los
otros libros electrónicos bajan pues
entonces nuestra curva va a cambiar
hacia la izquierda así que el precio de
los otros productos también está
cambiando mi relación entera por lo
tanto está cambiando toda la demanda y
es por eso que estoy poniendo aquí la
demanda va a cambiar hacia la derecha si
los precios de los otros libros
electrónicos aumentan de precio y me
gustaría que quedara este punto claro
cuando llevamos a cabo
todo lo demás igual nos estamos moviendo
a lo largo de una curva de demanda dada
básicamente estamos diciendo la demanda
es decir la relación entre la cantidad
de demanda y el precio se mantiene
constante y entonces nosotros podemos
escoger un precio y para éste tendremos
una cierta cantidad demandada estamos
avanzando a lo largo de la curva si
cambiamos una de esas cosas realmente lo
que estamos haciendo es cambiar la curva
una vez que cambia esta tabla de la
demanda lo que va a pasar es que va a
cambiar la curva ahora sí vamos a ver
que hay otros productos relacionados que
no forzosamente tienen que ser
sustitutos vamos a tomar el escenario 2
en el cual va a aumentar el precio
supongamos del lector de libros
electrónicos y ahora date cuenta que el
lector de libros electrónicos no es un
sustituto las personas pueden o no
comprar un libro electrónico o ellos
pueden no comprar mi libro electrónico y
sin embargo comprar un lector de libros
electrónicos para leer otros libros es
por eso que el lector de libros
electrónicos es un complemento pues la
gente realmente necesita un lector de
libros electrónicos o un ipad para leer
mi libro electrónico por lo tanto este
es un complemento ahora si el precio del
complemento llega a ser más costoso
es decir una de las cosas que la gente
podría utilizar para comprar mi libro
esto va a ser en realidad que sea cual
sea el precio de mi libro electrónico la
cantidad de personas que demanden este
libro baje en esta situación si mi libro
es de dos pesos van a existir menos
personas que van a tener un lector de
libros electrónicos o tal vez han
utilizado parte de su dinero para
comprar el lector de libros electrónicos
y por lo tanto tienen menos dinero para
comprar mi libro o puede ser que
entonces menos personas puedan comprar
el lector de libros electrónicos para
cualquier precio dado va a bajar la
cantidad de demanda eso es lo importante
por lo tanto la curva de la demanda se
va a trasladar hacia la izquierda y
justo esto es lo que sucede en el
escenario número 2 y viceversa si
bajamos el precio de lector de libros
electrónicos entonces cambiará mi curva
de la demanda hacia la derecha así que
realmente te animo a pensar y dibujar
por ti todos los escenarios posibles y
pensar en algún producto podría ser un
libro electrónico o cualquier otro tipo
de producto y pensar sobre lo que
pasaría si cambias el precio también
cuáles son sus sustitutos sus
complementos y luego en pensar qué es lo
que va a pasar si el precio de estos
cambia y siempre teniendo en cuenta
la diferencia entre la demanda que es
toda la relación completa toda la curva
sobre la cual nos podemos mover si
mantenemos todo lo demás igual y solo
cambiar el precio y la cantidad
demandada que es una cantidad
determinada por un precio concreto y
además manteniendo todo igual